in 2013 grand theft auto 5 which would
become the crown jewel of the franchise
at six billion dollars of revenue this
makes it the single biggest grossing
entertainment product of all time and
there is only one word for that and that
is damn this thing is done more than
avatar 2.8 billion around the world this
thing costs two hundred and fifty
million dollars to make which is more
than avatar and more than the first
Avengers remember the first Avengers
movie we all set there oh my gosh look
at this what they pulled together look
at the graphics look at everything this
cost more to make then Avengers it cost
more to make than avatar
we already got video game franchises now
that are more successful than movies in
terms of revenue more expensive to make
the movies so bigger bets and bigger
rewards it shows you where the future of
interactive entertainment is it's in
video games more than it is in cinema
and in cinema they like to talk about
opening box office they like to talk
about the first weekend uh-huh well
watch this
6 million were pre-ordered at $60 each
which means before it was ever released
they had 1.8 billion dollars of revenue
that was already gonna be marked on the
books pretty amazing stuff when you
think about what's happening now
something I also mentioned here I said
that this was the number three video
game in units of all time well gee Tom
what were the top two
they were these number two all-time is
minecraft a hundred and forty-four
million units over its life and number
one of course it's this the beloved
Tetris a hundred and seventy million
units all time including a hundred
million in mobile now I know something
about Tetris and mobile does it company
I was privileged to be a part of jammed
at mobile actually reached around the
world and consolidated ownership and
licensing for Tetris and later that
would be part of the sale of jammed at
mobile to Electronic Arts right here at
the first asterisk in seventeen they
announced in there one of their earnings
report that they were about 64% digital
delivery meaning you don't have to go
down to gamestop or Best Buy and buy the
box product you're actually getting
digital delivery on your console that
takes a lot of the
the product shipping creating out of it
and allows easier upgrading through the
digital version just like on your phone
an app gets a digital upgrade it's easy
to put a fix or a feature things in
through the digital version well now
they've indicated 2018 that they are now
up to 81% digital delivery what that
means is 81% of the products delivered
by take-two are now delivered digital
delivery which means when they get their
$60.00 there's no cost for the software
there's no cost for the product
packaging there's no cost for shipping
and there's no cost to Best Buy because
you're buying it now directly from the
publisher in most cases so when you take
a look at it the combination of the
Grand Theft Auto franchise going through
the roof the six billion dollars worth
of Revenue and a hundred million units
and digital delivery come together
that's what happens to your stock price
this week on case studies with the biz
doc on the value teaming channel over on
YouTube